Justin Timberlake's new concert film
just hit Netflix today and surprisingly
JT told our Cameron Mathison that he's a
little nervous about people seeing it
how excited are you for your fans to see
the song nervous because there's not a
character yeah that I can sort of hide
behind her talked about it said like yo
let's move front and center in his suit
and bowtie this is JT the musician doing
his thing for the fans but tlf that's
what this show is for cameras everywhere
as Justin in his 25 member band the
Tennessee kids take over Vegas for the
final stop on the 20/20 experience world
tour
oscar-winner Jonathan Demi the guy
behind the Silence of the Lambs directed
and in the process became one of JT's
biggest fans what makes my head explode
is trying to understand the way this man
took all those visual elements and
musical elements how did you do it how
did you dream all that stuff up oh my
god how the hell did you do it do you
put a bunch of geniuses around you I try
to do that and then you take all the
credit